the Joe Rogan experience you know we
just got done making fun about Kyle
kolinsky got in trouble for making fun
of Elizabeth Warren's dancing he didn't
get in trouble that the cory booker guy
went out like that is nonsense you
virtual signaling dummy that is so silly
if he made fun of everything he made fun
of cory booker's just a joke he made fun
of the thing that's that but if he makes
fun of Elizabeth Warren all of a sudden
it's sexist if I take his quote well you
see what he said it like it was so
clunky like I'm sorry you had 18
year-old autistic college students get
to talk for the first time yeah yeah
he's so clunky yeah how did you
formulate this this sentence did you
really feel this then and who do you
thinks gonna believe this yeah but the
people who are gonna believe this what
you would they already like you then
most of the people are gonna see right
through this thing so it was just to me
it's like you know it's a schizophrenic
message from people like that with
Elizabeth Warren's defenders it's like
well women can women can do anything
except take a joke dance watch your
dance let's watch that video Elizabeth
Warren desi if you're not making fun of
that you're out of your [ __ ] mind if
there's a thing to make fun of why do
white people think this is dancing by
the way you ever notice that George Bush
dance to my balls move and then then she
does this to undo that
I think Ellen maybe may do that I don't
know
Elon must do to de Cielo Neal uncle
China took his jacket off threw it on
the ground was dancing it's having a
good time I guess that's okay I gotta
cuz that pops yeah he's not running for
anything exactly yeah and everybody made
fun of it nobody accused anybody being
sexist really yeah dancing was hilarious
we'll play that first well played that
second let's play the Elizabeth Warren
one first because it Elizabeth Warren
won it's so [ __ ] ridiculous
you're watching her dance and you're
like how how dare you say I can't make
fun of this how dare you how dare you
fine obviously it's by the way it's not
like somebody put up a cellphone video
of her dancing at a wedding no one's
gonna get make know was that's okay
you're gonna she's on stage trying to
get something from people and she thinks
this will get it for her here we go here
she goes oh here she goes
here she's up there
I don't know if you can play that music
so she decided yeah we can't play that
music so it's uh look at her look at her
dancing so first of all [ __ ] this isn't
that no there's no one with Julian
Castro is in the background this is a
different one this is her oh there she
goes though oh no she did there do ya oh
no that would oh no she keeps doing this
if she looks like her back is welded
like I saw what yes you're right she's
barely real it's about being white mmm
you know those weird because I thought
she's Native American well that's what I
said you know but so obviously Bernie's
lying about saying women can't win or
Elizabeth Warren is lying about him
saying that and I'm not gonna accuse a
Native American of lying I'm just not
gonna go good for you
she is one one-thousandth Native
American so that's that's real that's a
real number so it might be mm she's 70
that hot her moves shouldn't be like
very elastic right that's a lot of 70
year old around there
good point 70 she actually looks pretty
good for 70 cuz Bernie looks like [ __ ]
right Bernie's head is in the middle of
his chest it's like it's like falling
off if I was his friend I'd be like bro
you got to work on your posture we got
to get you some spinal decompression
okay do some yoga classes you're gonna
your head's gonna fall when you meet him
he's taller than you think right that's
right for you yeah you meet him like oh
I thought it's supposed to be up here I
thought for sure I was gonna be taller
than him when I met him you ever have
that happen I thought for sure I'm gonna
be too or uh any any was he's way too
taller than me
well I'm five eight I always assumed I'm
shorter than everybody oh okay pretty
much so unless they like a tiny person
[Applause]